man you know the truth check me out man
on the bootleg kid podcast man Ralphie
[__] man keep the truth Along Gang in
bootleg cat podcast special guest in
here my guy Ralphie the plug
a big weekend coming up for you this
weekend yeah I got a little pop-up at um
Desto store yeah for my um exotic pop
it's like exotic pop meet and greet
mixtape release
uh just a 4-1 type of thing you know
what I'm saying quick meet and greet
type just want a soda all right got some
merch well you still have like you have
a you had a water that was your own
water that was out yeah the water that
did kind of good and now it's the soda
what's the flavor of the soda French
vanilla french cream vanilla type so
it's like vanilla ice cream kinda
um
for the mud sippers you know I gave
something for the month sippers to
cleanse themselves yes and get them
demons off so it's a good combination
yeah you gotta get one in one you gotta
go cool cup cool cup okay our dub pina
colada you know I've never I've never
sipped the mud
don't try again it's good and it's
addicting I've heard it's very addictive
have you ever tried to get off of it I
literally just got off it for a month
and
three weeks was it rough
nah nah because after the first little
four days you know so during okay that
four days is it like withdrawals though
up you throw up okay I just throw up
that's it so you'll be [__] only for
like one day though okay I Gotta Throw
it once [__] your stomach and my stomach
be [__] up so I can't eat you can't
eat before that yeah that's just me well
that's good though you could lose a
little weight cause I'm sure the lean
had some wings I'll be knocking [__]
back food
smacking [__] make you eat too soon and
you drink tons of soda yes that's a lot
of sugar cleansing myself with that holy
water man have you ever tried to sip
lean with diet soda
I don't think it's gonna give it the
same like smacked like a Diet Sprite
yeah I mean like you know
that could be a Vibe I feel like the
healthiest way you could do it you right
the healthiest way it's not healthy Let
Me Be Quick kind of sound kind of like
smart but it is smart because what
because most people who have lean gut
it's because they just drink soda all
[__] day yeah Sugar Sugar [__] that
Diet Coke got zero calories that Diet
Sprite Zero calories you might have to
try that with this nah I think that's
gonna [__] I think I tried it on an
accident one day and it was like
not it cause it get a Diet Sprite ain't
got enough sugar
Diet Sprite no no it tastes like their
sugar it's called aspartame
bro
firstly for somebody who'll drink this
all day you're gonna know us immediately
well obviously this is a coffee Yeah
Yeah from 7-Eleven yeah they got good
coffee you know good coffee yeah shout
out to the 7-Eleven
um what's been going on man obviously
you you just put is the deluxe to your
uh project out the 35 song joint or is
that what's up
the 12 songs that was already okay
is dropping on us like it in there two
for one type [__] like I mean I saw you
have there's 35 songs yeah 35 but you
basically get the list to the song
that's already out right now so people
think it's out that's like a triple
piece bruh but on the first one I had 32
so I had to add three more only reason
why I did it like that because when I
made the hard copies you can only do 31
songs well I think you're a certain
amount of minutes a certain amount of
minutes before you have to print two
discs exactly so I reached a minute so
I'm like all right [__] take a song
off type two uh I saw like last was it
last year you had or was it earlier this
year you had teased the possibility of a
deluxe of you and Draco [__] no it's
still coming it really got pushed back
because uh the legendary tape had
dropped
of course of course of course how is
it's got to be nice to have a guy like
Greedo home right yeah hell yeah we did
a cool video too that's all day yeah
that [__] was crazy it's a
little AI little effects and [__] have
you guys uh talked about doing a collab
project maybe you know what greeters the
work is easy we just get it in type [__]
I feel like he's got like that like high
output like yeah just like you and your
brother have like that's him and catch
you just like who I got it from just
that crazy out like output of just
like I remember like I was talking to TK
and I was like how many this was like
maybe last year I was like how many uh
Greedo songs he's like bro there's like
a thousand and October Brothers it was a
thousand before he went in
well because like he was recording like
he wasn't gonna get out for a very long
time so it's like you know you got to
keep keep up the output like and he was
dropping in videos I remember I went to
the studio one day around the studio
that [__] did
15 songs the next day shot 15 mini music
videos so I'm like this [__] on some
[__] right now well every time I see you
you always have your videographer with
you is that something that you kind of
learned from being around those guys are
just because you're very on point with
your visuals I kind of like Incorporated
that like a year after what 2021
yeah it's like I've been trying to do it
but I couldn't find like the right
cameraman that was just like you got
yeah right Cameron they gotta know
what's up yeah I mean [__] cameraman low
key would be [__] security guard too
you gotta make sure your cameraman ain't
no [__] so you can't be you know you're
gonna get robbed of his [__] camera
that should be happening
[__] happens
that would be incredible videographers
be getting hit up bruh
I just had a homie go to the bay and he
lost all his [__] because he got bipped
yeah that's [__] up it's crazy man
um so for you uh the Exotic pop the
water wasn't with him this is a you know
it was within so okay so this is your
first soda though yeah this is my first
soda and there this is exotic pop that's
not the same company that's not rap
snacks I'm thinking of this coming out
of cops out here exotic pop Texas I
think they got raps next to it if I'm
mistaken they got rap snacks so it's out
of Pop's Base in Texas yeah so did you
go out there did you like how does this
work do you like try flavors do they mix
it up and like you're like I like that I
like this you know you just say I want
french vanilla figure it out pop man the
good one you let me see yeah that one
type [__] you know I mean them shits is
everywhere now I was just at a store and
I saw Mac Dre soda yeah they got
actually like a peach [__] vanilla
type can that's like this big
the image is fire but if you want to
post some mud in the [__] You
Gotta Buy like three or three folding
[__] all that sugar and then they
like ten dollars a piece so you're gonna
it's gonna have to cost too much so um
the last time uh you came on the show
you brought uh the otm guys no they're
not seeing too many more is this correct
no they just owed to him you know is it
all is it positive is it negative they
went their separate ways or sidewalks
you know so there's no it's no animosity
no they just didn't
continue the business that was already
on the floor you know what I'm saying so
who's uh is there any new artists on
State team or what's sting team looking
like nowadays uh little player I'm
trying to get uchis I'm trying to get
this little [__] out Detroit too oh
Detroit man I feel like yo Detroit has
such a natural
cohesion with I just think like yeah
it's the [__] talking right I've been
saying it though like it's the you know
like because think team is like a
different kind of La type of [__] for
sure when we came how we [__] talking do
we do it's like yeah some of my favorite
[__] that your brother has something you
know what I mean like shout out to Peezy
man already go crazy got crazy to be
going crazy big ghetto crazy
um how's the father life treating you
man
I just had a son I got a daughter but my
kids they like especially my son he
think like well my daughter too small
but my son
yeah he just graduated today do you let
your kid because my son is eight well
he's nine now
and he be on that YouTube man YouTube
but he be looking at like
weird games yeah like and you know they
be trying to send little subliminal
messages in between but you know we
gotta take them off YouTube you think so
what what kind of supplemental messages
all type of weird [__] baby trying to
push a certain hoods into that I mean
really they trying to push that lgbtq
and nothing against it but you know they
be trying to push it a little too hard
kindergarten is crazy did you see uh in
Glendale there were some protests no you
know did you see that yeah there was a
protest in Glendale and the Armenians
were yeah you know they don't play that
[__]
I said [__] like getting right in front
of school
oh man them Armenians don't [__] around
bruh I think they only been priests I
mean they don't even put sex ed that
much in school like that so that's my
thing is like I think after
like if you want to do certain [__] and
teach people about certain like stuff
that's out make sure y'all handle all
the [__] that's already out there I
think like if you're gonna do that don't
do that before sex ed yeah you wouldn't
you wouldn't do that prior to teaching a
kid sex ed and I don't think we learned
sex ed until maybe like seventh or
eighth grade maybe yeah that's why I was
just telling someone like seven eighth
grade that's when they start really like
coming to school handing out the
contract and [__] 100 man 100
um anything uh for you okay so for this
is the deluxe coming out this weekend
yeah on Friday but yeah it should be
coming up Friday at nine but it's really
12 in New York yo I noticed a lot of
people
the guy who does all your artwork is he
from Detroit no I think he from like
London or something okay I've just
noticed I I've noticed everybody's using
him now yeah you kind of Set It Off me
and Draco because I was in um he did
that um I was in Detroit and someone
passed me I think it was a kid's names
Doug Hardin passed me his his tape or
whatever
and I was like that's the same guy be
doing all the Ralphie Draco [__] it's
the same [__] like he did that
thank you for using GTL yeah it's great
for that it was fine
um who is there anybody else in La that
you uh that you've been uh checking out
that maybe we should be hip too because
I do feel like you got you here to the
street I mean I know you're you're I
think last time you told us about a
bunch of dope artists in stock
the young [__] like whenever I Brown's
Body [__] like
Jacy [__] R3 he be talking crazy
R3 from uh where's he from San
Bernardino yeah yeah you got some [__]
going right now they do they got a lot
of little rappers yeah it feels like all
the random like cities that are kind of
shunned by the big cities have been
popping in in Cali like Stockton is lit
yeah no they is I've been every time I
look on this damn they stocked in my
[__] I remember what I was saying
that [__] that's what make it even crazy
ebk guys and obviously uh shout out to
uh edges everybody stock is crazy Haiti
babies on [__] just got signed to
Jeezy yeah
everybody would you ever sign to a major
label Ralphie
man one thing about the labels they
gotta be on my program but we can make
some money because you're very
self-sufficient yeah like you drop when
you want you want to you if you want to
drop some shits like you kind of it's
kind of crazy like you do have a very
self-contained operation going on where
you don't really need much from anybody
so it's like if you want to drop a music
video or you want to drop a song do you
do distro kid to Encore how do you get
this okay so much he's going crazy on
this right come on what's been your best
month on distro kid because you have a
catalog like 50 damn
but like 30 40 is regular that's like
normal 50 50 was like crazy because how
many how many projects do you have out
Independence at least 20. crazy and that
should just and then know the singles
all the features I do for all the
artists I [__] with yeah because they
got to give you your cut-off districts
that's why I like distro kid because if
you got a producer yeah I got you I was
just in mind you we inspired everybody
to go distro so now they go this road
and they're like all right I'm gonna add
you to the [__] yeah it's like for sure
yeah a lot of people was trying to go
major until they realize like nah Draco
going crazy how the [__] he going this
crazy a lot of people definitely I'm so
like like that's one thing about
2023 I mean [__] the last five years
like if you really you really don't need
much you see me cameraed up all day yeah
setting up your deals but if they label
one and like you know do some marketing
right or just drop you off a stupid bag
for like an album yeah album because we
ain't doing nothing to like you're gonna
be locked in yeah yeah I'll get y'all a
little [__] if it don't work all right
it's cool we ain't even gonna do no more
business why do you feel because I do
feel like because they don't push you
they're not gonna push it true if they
give you let's just to think about it on
the smaller scale
if they only give you 50 000 why are
they going to put 250 000 into your
mixtape to go number one true that right
the numbers don't that's what I tell
artists I'm like hey it's either your
fan base or gonna recoup it you're gonna
get yeah you're gonna get in advance
you got to make that [__] last because
it's gonna be hard to recoup it so you
got to get that you gotta get that live
money popping or you got to get them
side deals some side hustles you're
supposed to already have a catalog so
now when you come it's like all right
well let's just start fresh
they're gonna try to take your catalog
no you can have the last two mixtapes
right yeah
so you can have the last two mixtapes
and we can do one more what's up y'all
we gotta stop the interview real quick
to tell you about our good friends at my
bookie that's right it is NBA Finals you
gotta Hammer the Nuggets I don't know
they might sweep the the heat I would
look at the
like serious odds on that go to my
bookie right now let's get some money
man all right baseball of course is in
full effect we got Stanley Cup finals
NFL seasons on the way sign up at
mybookie.ag right now use the promo code
bootleg and you will get that first
deposit bonus all right look I don't
care where you're at you can go to
mybookie.ag Let's gamble on some sports
they got the casino you can do live
Blackjack you can do live roulette craps
you could do all kinds of slots and of
course bet on the NBA Finals bet on the
NHL uh Stanley Cup finals crazy shots of
the Vegas golden knights that's what I'm
rooting for and of course baseball
season man all right so look right now
mybookie.ag use that promo code bootleg
uh and sign up when you do use uh that
promo code they're going to give you a
first deposit bonus straight to your
account free money all right mybookie.ag
go do that also got to give a shout out
to our family at Blue chew that's right
ladies and gentlemen it's getting hot
outside that means
I don't know what that means it's just
hot so I feel like when it's hot people
want to [__] more right so you know
fellas if you're dealing with erectile
dysfunction it happens to the best of us
I'm sure maybe you are old maybe you are
dealing with stress at work maybe you
don't want to sleep with the same lady
that you're married to over and over
need a little extra motivation to get
that thing stayed up you know what I
mean go to uhboochu.com use the promo
code bootleg and they'll send it
straight to your door three-month supply
of Bluetooth for free all right now
there's Bluetooth work yes it does
you're gonna get a free month supply to
be able to see for yourself blue
shoe.com promo code bootleg uh now if
you don't know what it is it is the same
active ingredient as Viagra and Cialis
but in a chewable form and you do not
have to go to a doctor's appointment all
right you do everything online you don't
have to go sit at a doctor's office and
talk to some old man in a lab coat about
your dick issues not necessary anymore
in 2023 all right so go to Bluetooth
sign up with that promo code bootleg get
a month supply for free let's get back
to the interviews has anybody a lot of
artists are selling their catalogs has
anyone tried to buy your catalog I
wouldn't sell it just because what I
learned from Drake all that because I
think I want to say
somebody who did we just talk to that
said they sold like
a bunch of their tapes off
someone just as L.A rapper
they just like took a bag for a bunch of
mixtapes that were like older they were
like I don't give a [__] like little
shits are like they gave him like a
million dollars or something oh no [__]
no million bucks someone's like give me
10 year projects for a million I already
made half a million already yeah yeah
yeah
that's a smart hey that's the smart
that's the smart thought process because
most people are they like that low
hanging fruit that easy enough you're
gonna buy it you're gonna buy everything
I've been buying all these years right
and then you're gonna be set back
because now you can't get that little 20
30 40 a month
and they ain't gonna never tell you when
you were recruit let me ask you this I
do feel like you guys have always been
kind of quote-unquote anti-industry
that's only because the industry never
really like [__] with us you know but I
also feel like y'all outside of L.A
though right right I just mean in terms
of like I feel like
and I mean I just saw you uh pull up to
the cookies a whole lot of [__] with
Desto and burning you see how in real
life the fans yeah for sure can't do
nothing
um do you think if you played the
politics game a little bit more just on
the industry side I'm not talking about
streets because that's LA's you know
Mountaintop music
do you feel like it could help you out a
lot more
I mean or do you just not care
they will have to like show me what they
can do like I just feel like I feel like
the thing is with labels they don't
really show you I'm not even talking
about the label [__] I'm not even
talking about that I just mean like
maybe networking or whether or not like
oh like it's just like you talking about
like just marketing and [__] it's about
everything like okay BT weekend are you
moving around are you chilling
weekend and get all my like or if if you
if you get an invite to the Spotify
event are you gonna go or not
hell yeah okay well then because I feel
like that's the kind of [__] for
whatever reason like just those little
relationships you might make with just
random people at Spotify or apple music
or
and I know it's like super trash to like
I hate I'm not a rapper but I hate going
anywhere I like my house yeah I played a
game and [__] record all day right
but my thing is is like some I feel like
with as an artist like it is beneficial
to kind of like you know I go shopping
to go hang out like if there's like a
dope industry event I don't know what
ratchet [__] like I mean like you know
hey oh [__] there's a rap caviar man
yeah if it's a bunch of players dude you
got to go rub shoulders a little bit
yeah just you know if it's some players
there for sure uh anything
um new going on with uh I know your your
guys's family was suing that was it the
city of La or the LAPD or uh promoters
Live Nation anything going on with the
Live Nation lawsuit it's been since
Corona so I don't know we just sit and
wait but sitting and waiting I'm having
a business so you know yeah you're
making you're making you're making sure
you're not sitting around like waiting
to see what happens yeah now I can
imagine man yeah so I think it's crazy
because
I've been to like events recently and I
feel like
that lawsuit has shaken up the music
industry because now when you go to
these festivals it is crazy how like
you're out of there like you perform and
you have to leave like I think I think
people already was when I went to
one director went on
the bay no where was it here where was
that room now
legendary performance for sure man any
more uh Loki had his mic [__] up did
they yeah you seen it in his face he was
like yeah and [__] but he was you know
what though his tone is so like I feel
like draco's tone know what it is is I
think
DJs have a habit of playing music too
loud or yeah too fast for sure they
might hop on they wanna it might be plus
four energy Vibe yeah for sure but we be
well when you do live when you're DJing
an artist set you can't you can't have
their [__] sped up that's crazy yeah no
it's a wild situation uh any uh how much
more Draco music sitting on a hard drive
somewhere is there a lot left or not
that much this this is enough to drop
like at least three four mixtape
depending on how many songs but you can
drop deluxes EPS thing it's just there's
so much like I'm gonna drop the code in
hell in the deluxe yeah they keep the
truthful out Deluxe and then it's just
like I don't know what the name nothing
else
have you had any uh
instances where you've had to pull down
get sentences and desist out to people
putting out like unauthorized [__] oh
yeah if it's not an authorized you got
it gets it down because it's not
authorized yeah I mean that's a standard
it's such a that's such a weird thing to
do to like put out a song with somebody
who's not here anymore and think that
it's just gonna fly especially if it's
not like all right you finna drop it all
right drop it like they don't reach out
you gotta make sure the business is
right first
with everything 100 are you in charge of
handling a lot of that I mean like
the state is in charge yeah but you're
gonna need okay from some yeah you're
gonna make sure he's not looking crazy
if it's like some random rapper from
like [__] Montana or something like
it's Gotta make sense
so it could be anybody [__] the bag is
right at the business is right the
business is right is good
um I feel like the last time I saw you
did you have a weed thing going yeah is
that is that a wrap you know I still do
my exotic stinky Buzz Ralphie runs we
got and then Chief and be doing this
thing too so I feel like the Wii game as
a rapper is very like hit or miss yeah
people think it's like you just print
money and you it's not gonna have money
to buy the the Wii
see they can just jump into some [__]
with no money you can't jump into
nothing with no money you need money to
do everything obviously you [__]
missed to get on the bus ain't that the
truth we live in California the
epicenter of marijuana culture No Cap
what's your favorite strain
don't say your own things don't say it
nah I'll be up like all time
I ain't gonna lie be off like some real
good cookie shot it got to be something
like some [__] like the actual cookie
strain the Girl Scouts because some Girl
Scout cookies like some blue cookies
something meant like some monster cookie
like back when I was smoking like 2016.
that was that [__] like weed was
pressure like it was like damn like let
me see oh yeah you got that good cause
yeah right do you feel like the the weed
is oh yeah it's the quality is water
down that's because they start mixing
everything they're trying to get the
most exotic [__] like I feel like
hi gelatos came they just make some gas
OG with some [__] cookies type [__]
yeah I do feel like at times people are
like they they especially if you like
you sell drugs and like you'll show a
pack to somebody and they're so like
what's what's what's it look like as
opposed to like how's the smell and how
does it smoke I want to smell it tasty
how does it smoke let me roll it is it
gonna get you high or not [__]
are so like ah man I don't know man with
that look they want the look they want
to look because it looked like that and
that's when you start mixing all these
[__] plants together and you get all
this okay weed that just looks wild yeah
you got a bunch of lemon cherries
floating around and [__] everybody's
smoking and then there's like certain
certain weed where you'll smell it and
you'll be like how's it smell that way
bro like what's going on to make that
[__] smell that way there's some other
[__] in there you know what I'm saying
like they've no they got moves I ain't
gonna tell her they moves but they got
moves man like they put a little [__]
like a little [__] you mean like a
little [__] yeah they probably put like
a half
ounce of um
oh yeah
yeah have it like it like oh hold on
yeah is yeah you'll mix like a a quarter
of a pound of like straight Exotics with
like the rest of it'll be like some cool
you know some cool light depths yeah you
know
oh yeah they be trying to get me up like
man hell no well and then that's the
other thing right is there's the
smallest rabbit almost so right now the
smalls are popping but they're popping
everywhere but La so like if you go to
like Detroit or you go to New York
everyone has Smalls because La weed
consumers are so [__] bougie that
because the nug is Tiny they don't think
it's good and it's like it's the same
thing so all these Smalls are getting
[__] they're booming you know shops
hit La big though that's why yeah so
people that's buying weed like
they've been buying [__] from shops for
a long time damn they're going to go get
10 grams for twenty dollars and [__] so
like
they wanted to be like you they bougie
out here I don't know what it is for
sure that's probably what it is though
they was going to shops getting 20
[__] 10 grams and [__] have you been
to New York recently no I'm about to go
out there for a show supposedly yeah
what is it Brooklyn New York's crazy and
[__] August I think New York's the
Wild Wild West right now you walk
through New York yeah I heard there's
people with fold up tables you're
selling shrooms and weed everywhere in
front of cops no one cares that's why
the police be on everybody that's that's
not now no they ain't all nobody no more
bro you go to New York right now you
let's say you walk into like the liquor
store dang I don't know about man that
[__] little TJ just went to jail three
times for the same [__] bro if you go to
a liquor store in New York right now
behind the counter they have raw shrooms
and weed
right it is insane New York is the wild
wild west of the drug game right now
it's lit as [__] it seemed like this
it seemed like they just be balancing
out on rappers and [__] like heavy on
them no no but not on weed anymore it's
all good they all they care about is
guns don't hey look if you're in New
York anybody got a gun on them get the
[__] away hell no we don't be doing that
type of [__] but I'm saying like because
Lil Wayne that's how Wayne got locked up
see that that's why they own [__] they
ain't that that's exactly they ain't
known like regular people that's the one
[__] no they don't care about weed
though
white table with a bunch of drugs on it
they don't give a [__] oh yeah they
going crazy they taxing too New York is
lit yeah
it's wild yeah it's wild
for sure for it it's it's definitely uh
it's different and I was saying I want
to do a pop-up before I do a
do the show so I can have like all the
New York people that's actually out
there run ads and [__] on all the little
page gotta stop the interview to tell
you about our family at Odd Socks that's
right the most comfortable socks in the
world ladies and gentlemen uh go to
oddsocksofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg Cav or bootleg both promo codes
work you'll save 20 out at checkout uh
20 off these are the odd Sox Basics all
right now you can get like a pack of all
black pack of all whites of course they
got all kind of crazy licenses WWE
Cheech and Chong they got Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles they got SpongeBob
SquarePants bruh look they got the
SpongeBob SquarePants Krabby Patty
draws
yeah now you don't want crabs but you do
want Mr crab's underwear because these
are fire all right so look go to
oddsocksofficial.com right now use that
promo code uh bootleg save 20 off a
checkout and uh yeah listen trust me
when I say most comfortable socks you'll
ever put on your [__] feet
and the most comfortable boxer briefs
what are we talking about man all right
oddsoxofficial.com promo code bootleg
save 20 off of checkout great gift and
and just treat yourself all right also
got a shout out to our family a King
Palm now if you guys don't know about
King pong kingpong is all natural baby
yes all right we're talking about the
leader when it comes to uh tobacco-free
natural organic Leaf wraps if you're a
smoker a toad or a straight west coaster
you know what I'm saying whatever you're
into King Palms they got it for you
what's great about
um these these are like one of the best
uh products that they sell now this is a
terpene infused tobacco-free leaf
and what's dope is you stuff your flour
into it
and then you press on the thingy you
know what I'm saying and then you got
flavor I'm going to show you what it
looks like when it's stuffed
with some great tree from Jardin of
course
ah look at that
all right get that thing stuffed up
the tip has got that flavor in it uh
wherever you're at man make sure you
check out the uh
um you know they got the smoke shops
they got those on lock they got
7-Elevens on lock we only smoking out of
King Palms baby you already know what it
is and if you go to
kingpoms.com
kingpom.com kingpom.com
and you use the promo code bootleg Kev
you will save 50 off at checkout
half off at checkout 50 off if you go to
kingpom.com and use that promo code the
promo code is down below go run it up
try some of these flavors too man the
peach pineapple the Strawberry Shortcake
they just got so much going on there's
also all kind of dope smoking
accessories you can get half off y'all
what are we talking about save 50 off
kingpom.com promo code below it's either
bootleg or bootleg have them these promo
codes got my head hurt try both of them
all right one of them get you 50 off God
damn it anyway let's get back to the
interview what's your um number one
market outside of Cali
when you look at the Phoenix Phoenix
I mean when I look at the numbers though
[__] the end of the UK and like
Australians wow yeah let me show you
Australia is a vibe look at this [__] oh
my Spotify
it's like I get the same amount of
numbers I get more numbers and
Australia than I get in [__]
Phoenix so Phoenix is your biggest city
outside of uh Cali I feel like it's like
what you think outside the county
Phoenix Vegas
but Oregon Portland yeah Portland yeah
but up and down the West Coast
look at Australia Australia's booming oh
Sacramento [__] which oh Seattle there
you go it's Seattle and Phoenix look how
much more I'm getting in Australia then
well that's a country yeah Australia's
lit yeah oh yeah that is a commercial
thank you Australia is a wild place I
got all the real animals there man you
got Australia them [__] kangaroos
[__] your [__] up bro [__] that's just
one song too huh that's just one song
you ever hook up with a rapper from out
there like a [__] might like a
[__] you know [__] Australia hey
you should tap him bro ain't real [__]
right now he's popping out there doing
record he ain't got no rapper that link
with out there but I would love to
they'd probably not be great but you
know definitely why you would like the
London French Canada not a London
hip-hop scene is lit you guys
it is
nah he like he's like first right
yeah he's from Europe like that shout
out to French and freeze you're going
crazy let me show you this [__] I gotta
show you this [__] cause yeah he was
doing crazy I was like damn he sent me a
verse
you know how you like think something
yeah
sent it over he sent that [__]
all right his numbers is crazy
freeze I see him oh he got a record with
Central see I love Central C okay that's
big freeze big freeze this might be some
Novell or day he might hey this might be
French yeah [__] do you have a passport
I'm about to get one because I'm going
to all those places you got to man
you're leaving money on the table yeah
I'm gonna go out there do a pop-up in
all them places bruh yeah do a couple
beats do Studio takeovers how everybody
pull up What Not hell I ain't having
everybody pull up as you know y'all can
pull ups one at a time to my room knock
out some verses anything uh else going
on I I feel like for whatever reason I
feel like
you could have shoes
you got them on right yeah I gotta show
my shoes man this is
to bring out the samples today
oh these are crazy
how do you details how do you get these
made is it China yeah China got them
cooked up yeah hey those are hard how
much are those gonna go for what 250
250. that's not even terrible I ain't
even mad at that that's standard that's
a good sneaker for 250. they're called
the plugs geez yeah I'm thinking plug
walks hey they're not that some people
just get clowned for air walks back in
the days I like the plug walks you know
plug walking Rich the kid might be like
yo what's up you know it's my song She
Gotta holla at me
you're Ralphie the [__] yeah that's just
a Song Plug yeah um for sure man well
[__] uh Friday the deluxe is out
um the video with um Greedo [__] uh
real life or fictional and then uh
you're gonna be is the soda gonna be
everywhere
well I'm gonna drop it right there first
I'm only gonna have like two cases and
I'm gonna get some more that's not me
but eventually yeah hell yeah you got
the big distro deal with the because
them shits is everywhere nah for sure
I'm finna go crazy anything else going
on
ah what do I got going on
what the [__] I got going on
yeah this weekend we've been preparing
for this mixtape other than cold then
how Deluxe that's another campaign
when's that crazy
I was thinking
in this summer but then if I don't want
to go towards the end of the summer
because I might as well drop it on his
birthday when's his birthday December
1st that's fair you know what I'm saying
but that'll be a long time no I I don't
even want to make people wait there no
you should drop it this summer yeah
because I feel like no you know we're
supposed to feel the Gap the legendary
tape that was supposed to like right so
people was gonna because this was
supposed to drop in May but everything I
pushed back so I'm like I'm just gonna
drop myself do you feel like uh you got
because I it's I always me and him
always talk when we hear like some of
these new rappers not even just from LA
but they just sound so much like you and
your brother nah for sure it's crazy
that's why when I how I switched my
whole flow everybody now we want you to
go why would I go back to that and
everybody want to rap like that yeah you
know yeah so you guys have a lot of
influence when it comes to like now
everybody's starting to rap like this
laid back oh my God that's so that's
literally what they do yeah it's pretty
crazy but should we be nonchalant
because we'd be pulled and [__] like
[__] don't just go on the boat and
acting normal and getting getting the
booth
get off the boat they back normal right
uh all right so Friday make sure you go
get the deluxe uh hopefully the cold day
in Hell Deluxe will be coming sooner
than later yeah no I might drop it
sooner my fans be on me
Friday damn get up man I'll be feeling
like I'm getting stuck up for the music
man don't don't do me
these fans are crazy no our fans don't
play they they go crazy yeah there's
certain people who can't post without
just being flooded with lld it's a lot
of people that can't post because they
don't the comments are
yeah the fans are [__] lit they just
show you like yeah y'all be trying to
block this [__] but we right here
[__] yeah I'm sure man well I
appreciate you pulling up man of course
uh go get the uh the deluxe of the
project tomorrow well if you're if
you're watching this it's already out so
go run that [__] up run it up
um anything else man
[__] not really man you should do a
[__] podcast that's what we trying to
do I don't know like but I can't just
run it what
he's right there but look I rap do merch
are you handling all your own merch
sales who else gonna touch my money I
don't know man I'm like man baby mama
Auntie I'm rapping mom
somebody that know how to do it yeah but
I'm rapping
merch
[__] it
studio all day investing what are you
investing in
jewelry and Studios and [__] like that
like it's jewelry a wise investment if
you're getting it at the prices I'm
getting it so you have to plug well
you're rocking the plug I mean I just
been buying jewelry so long I build
relationships so people just buy jewelry
just based off they get a little lump
sum of money and then they're walking to
Georgia and then they hit him I hit him
upside the head yeah they tell them the
price all right let's go me I'm like
hold on [__] them last couple shits I
bought they wasn't even this much why
are you trying to charge me I feel like
Jewelers take advantage of artists so
much it's so funny especially if you
super big if you're super big because
they'll pull up to the studio with the
suitcase handcuffed to their hands nah
no okay and then they got all this [__]
look at it like me when I be looking at
um [__] on my feature price like if
you look like you out here balling this
[__] this is what you do I'm gonna tell
you regular price but if you look like
you got 200 followers and you're trying
to like you might be like hey let me
help you out I like that what's the
what's the verse if I got 200 followers
what's the price
25 on it that's not bad no that's good
yeah 2500 why you think I got so many
random Ralphie features when you look on
is that is that a primary artist or no
we gotta talk
if your primary artist on a song it
depends on if you try to fake have your
manager hit me up with five minutes yeah
like why you got your management yeah
like you want the verse like but if you
know you got 200 followers how could you
afford this manage has there ever been
hey has there ever been a song that was
so terrible that you said no
I mean I probably don't do a lot of
verses based off of like quality I like
like you got to be gassing because if I
send somebody a verse I'm about to [__]
I think I'm gas and so so if it's trash
you'll say no I won't say no I probably
just won't do it I mean that's like
saying no
and that's the prices I don't want to
have to tell your [__] trash
or send me something else yeah I don't
even have to tell you that man you
should know send me that [__] or don't
send me nothing at all because like you
see what we doing around right now don't
try to send me a song to make better by
me hopping on it yeah no I feel you
brother well I appreciate you pulling up
Ralphie man always good to see you uh go
run up the music run up the catalog
catch you don't let the track go man lol
it can't keep the truth alive for sure
boom my God appreciate your brother we
got it hey appreciate y'all watching
another interview brought to you by our
good Folks at hardean now listen y'all
when you're in Las Vegas you get in that
[__] Uber you land at the airport hit
that taxi tell him to take you to hard
Dean the number one premium cannabis
dispensary in the [__] world y'all
I'm telling you you walk in they treat
you like a king or a queen or whatever
you're into all right they got the
craziest selection of Premium cannabis
you'll see period anyway let alone in
Las Vegas but just anywhere all right
not only can you go get the best tree
you will get the best experience but
best customer service the best bud
tenders you walk in the hard Dean and
that [__] just smells amazing they got
their own [__] scent literally you
get into my car I got a bottle of it my
car smells like Harding because it's
just the best [__] place
um go follow them online Harding
underscore Las Vegas
Harding underscore Las Vegas go to their
website
hardinglasvegas.com all right when you
go you're in Vegas you pull up tell them
I sent you they're gonna take care of
you the right way all right look they
got these things in there man these Moon
Rock uh pre-rolls that I just had that
just absolutely melted my face off
shout out to hard Dean all right you got
to go [__] with hard Dean man Jardine
underscore Las Vegas uh thank y'all man
I love these guys they're like family to
us and uh hey we're gonna drop another
interview soon if you're watching this
you're at the end of the interview
though much love